aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui a été victime
d'agressions sexuelles pendant sa
minorité aura jusqu'à l'âge de 48 ans
pour déposer plainte pour libérer sa
parole comme on dit et pour faire
examiner son affaire 48 ans et déjà un
âge très avancé à 48 ans si on n'a pas
découvert qu'on a été aussi on n'a pas
eu la possibilité encore de de dénoncer
ce que l'on croit avoir subi je ne sais
pas quel âge on pourra l être en mesure
de le faire et ça va poser quand même un
grave problème parce que que faire des
preuves que faire comment faire un
procès avec tout ça on le voit bien à
chaque fois que la parole a tardé on a
de plus en plus de mal à juger des
affaires toutes les victimes que j'ai pu
accompagner vend toujours tenu les mêmes
propos c'est à dire que peu importe ce
que dit la justice ce qui les intéresse
c'est que celui ou celle qu'elle dénomme
comme étant leurs agresseurs et reconnu
les faits c'est ça qu'il est guéri c'est
ça qui cautérise leur plaît et c'est pas
tellement c'est pas tellement le reste
en fait et le procès leur fait presque
plus de mal que de bien je ne suis pas
certaine que cette imprescriptibles
après script ibilité pardon soit
nécessaire elle n'existe pas par exemple
pour des crimes de sang or il ya plein
d'affaires qui ne sont pas résolues pour
lesquels on et marées que cette
prescription ne soit jamais atteinte
pour pouvoir si jamais la science évolue
faire évoluer le dossier mais en même
temps il ya un moment où il faut être
capable de passer à autre chose et de
s'arrêter parce que sinon c'est
impossible
et sinon on risque d'être avec des
histoires qui ont pu évoluer qui ont pu
changer et on aura aucune certitude de
rien
[Musique]